[Musik]
hier ist man hier auf senkung wie sie
das gehört dem bundestag an
[Musik]
krank gemacht bitte aus den fehlern zu
hüpfen
jetzt was soll das das ist immer ein
wenig an jenen auch stets wie es heute
ist dann für den anderen funktionieren
[Musik]
das ist schon sehr cool hier herzlich
ein bei den major pionieren
pionierbataillon 3 in melk in
niederösterreich direkt an der donau
das hat einen guten grund denn wissen
was wir hier erleben wir haben es hat
viel mit wasser zu tun aber noch viel
mehr mit der arbeit der pioniere oberst
koller kennt sich wirklich gut aus nicht
zuletzt dieser erobert hallo grüß ich
was machen die pioniere wir können
straßenbaum
wir können brücken errichten mit ihren
hindernisse wegsprengen
wir bauen feldlager überwinden gewässer
um sind auch in der katastrophenhilfe
wohlgesinnte helfer für die
zivilbevölkerung
und wenn ich sage was ausbildung
brückenbau verbauten sturm boote dabei
wasser aus den sturm wurde
jawohl können wir wenn man die stirn
boten sind genauer anschauen herzlich
gerne aber bevor wir das machen werden
wir schauen wir weiter die
wasserförderung der ausbildung
beherrscht rudern sein werk etc nur dann
bruder seinem sinn von rudern ja gut
dann einfach mit manneskraft lodern
[Musik]
wo kameraden wir setzen das brot und
übersetzen dollar abgibt
[Musik]
sehr gut gemacht es wird grundsätzlich
eine ausbildung bis 19 uhr geplant
gewesen kaufen wir uns nicht und wir
steigen direkt den sprung auf die stirn
bot ist gut für uns ist
[Musik]
es ist dass sturm bord des
österreichischen bundesheeres
klarerweise in der szene für
militärische einsatz aber das kannst du
gut ist hauptsächlich unsere
militärische aufgabe in fahrtrichtung
sitzen vor von gewässern prozent
aufgebessert währung zu retten bergen
ist schnell mit diesem boot wahnsinnig
mendig war das x10 was ist ihr antrieb
neun meter lang ist ein aluminium boot
mit einem chat andré ist dass ein teil
ihrer ausbildung das hier zum beispiel
wasser herunter gemacht ja das ist ein
essenzieller teil eingeführt ist
natürlich auch etwas was im zivilen dann
immer wieder zum einsatz kommt wenn zum
beispiel jemand ins wasser fällt
ich habe das mal ausprobieren ein
freiwilliger für eine bergung
amerikaner gerade also zumindest kann
ich meine gehör verschafft
wahrscheinlich weil ich einfach kennen
von dort bin wo man es dort zu probieren
gehst du denn man muss das boot lenken
[Musik]
hey hey hallo
resümee für heute hier waren sich ein
tolles gesehen hat gesehen was die
pioniere alles leisten und dabei haben
nur an bucht gesehen den er als möglich
mache als wegbereiter als die dafür
sorgen dass das bundesheer überall
seinem weg findet und war beeindruckt
sind das einmal zu sehen da zuzuschauen
die ausbildung der knights das schwere
gerät aber natürlich
sie haben ein stück fahren oder
[Musik]
zwei lange tage und
morgens wieder früher
abdi
was dann
[Musik]